Buonasera buonasera buonasera buonasera
buonasera
Non sarete mica stanchi eh siete stanchi
che dopo di me ce n'è altri otto mi
hanno detto vero su battente un po' le
mani a tempo fatemi sentire Dai dai dai
dai dai grazie grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie a tutti mi chiamo
Alessandro Lippi come ha detto la nostra
bellissima presentatrice un po' vi ha
spiegato chi sono e cosa faccio Non sono
un dj non sono un musicista Però io sono
qua questa sera su questo palco del Ted
ex Ferrara parlare di musica cosa ci
faccio qua a parlare di musica Perché la
musica era la mia passione era un hobby
e la musica può essere trasformata anche
nel mio lavoro perché il mio lavoro
appunto è raccontare la musica ricordo
esattamente quando è scattato dentro di
me qualcosa era la Primavera del nel
1992 mia nonna mi accompagna in
bicicletta sul lungomare di Viareggio
comprare la musicassetta in singolo vi
ricordate i singoli musicassetta ve li
ricordate di Michael Jackson Black Or
White torno a casa metto nello stereo e
dentro di me scatta qualcosa che ancora
oggi ricordo qualcosa che però non
riuscivo ancora a descrivere ero piccolo
non aveva ancora gli strumenti per
capire che quello sarebbe stato il mio
futuro Però una cosa era certa diventare
specialista di quella materia della
musica è stata Non solo un'ambizione ma
anche un'esigenza diventate specialisti
della vostra materia Questo è
l'insegnamento che il grandissimo
professore Umberto Eco per il quale vi
chiedo un grandissimo applauso
l'insegnamento che il professor Umberto
Eco dà ai suoi studenti era proprio
questo gli diceva diventate specialisti
della vostra materia e gli diceva la
vostra tesi di laurea deve essere il
lavoro numero uno di questa vostra
ricerca di questo vostro percorso Io
l'ho preso decisamente alla lettera il
professor Umberto Eco perché mi sono
laureato in semiotica con una tesi che
parlava della pista da ballo c'era
l'unico con le citazioni di David
Morales invece che di Schopenhauer però
andò decisamente molto bene la pista da
ballo la pista da ballo questo luogo
venerato come una chiesa da chi come me
la frequenta però per lavoro da 20 anni
demonizzata da tutti gli altri come la
peggiore delle eresie
Eppure la pista da ballo della quale mi
occupo avrebbe tutte le caratteristiche
per essere
raccontata un po' meglio per essere
trattata un po' meglio la pista da ballo
Innanzitutto è uno dei luoghi più
Democratici che ci sia sulla pista da
ballo siamo veramente tutti uguali senza
distinzione di razza di sesso e di
religione
ballare Poi ballare ballare
è un'esperienza
primordiale un'esperienza tribale
religiosa E come tutte le religioni ha
le sue divinità che sono i dj
le sue chiese che sono
le discoteche bravo ti ho vista il
Cocoricò a luglio mi ricordo
e i suoi sudditi verranno avanti che
siamo noi Nessuno escluso ve lo dimostro
Quanti di voi Qua presenti in sala hanno
mai scalato la vetta di una montagna
Speriamo di aver azzeccato l'esempio
Quanti di voi dei presenti in sala hanno
mai fatto il pane il pane con le mani il
pane quanti Su su non vi vedo bene
Quanti di voi dei presenti in sala sono
stati almeno una volta in discoteca
Avete visto siamo Una tribù che balla a
cui nessuno lo ha insegnato
nessuno ci ha mai insegnato a ballare
scritto nel nostro DNA lo dice nuovo in
un bellissimo documentario che si chiama
What we started e va in onda su Netflix
ve lo potete trovare qua che racconta
proprio questo racconta di come
50.000 anni fa l'umanità ballava intorno
al fuoco si radunava intorno alle
focolai le tribù ballavano intorno per
dei rituali magici che ricordano un po'
noi quando ci raduniamo per un concerto
è scritto nel nostro DNA tutto questo
Eppure ballare è ancora considerata a
volte un'arte sovversiva e illegale
Nonostante sia un'arte legale e
meravigliosa durante la pandemia di
coronavirus poi
sembra che nell'opinione pubblica vecchi
fantasmi mai addormentati si siano
svegliati No per dare adito a delle
polemiche ricordo che la parola
discoteca vi ricorderete quanto è stata
usata E abusata dai maestri italiani
spesso come capro espiatorio troppo
spesso come capro espiatorio di una
situazione decisamente fuori controllo
non è questa la sede del text Ferrara
per fare polemica naturalmente Però mi
vorrei concentrare su un aspetto
primordiale ancestrale che ricorda gli
antichi che 50.000 anni fa ballavano
intorno al fuoco quelli della slide che
non c'era ed era molto bella perché
avevo cercato quella foto tantissimo ed
era bellissima c'era il fuoco Vabbè
ricorda quella cosa là ricorda quella
cosa là ed è questo è un passaggio
fondamentale dell'umanità ed è un
passaggio fondamentale Non solo per la
nostra storia saremo in tutti i libri ma
anche per la storia della musica
contemporanea anche il fatto che per la
prima volta nella sua storia la musica
sia stata vietata ci sia stato vietato
andare a dei concerti a dei dj set dei
festival è una cosa che Ci ricorderemo e
porteremo sempre sulla nostra pelle
perché è una cosa primordiale ancestrale
Quando c'è stata tolta ce ne siamo
accorti e come se ce ne siamo accorti
raccontare con lucidità e obiettività
anche quest'ultimo passaggio molto
delicato per la storia della musica è
stata una delle mie ultime una delle mie
ultime missioni per cercare di sollevare
il mondo della discoteca al mondo della
notte e il mondo della musica
elettronica da pregiudizi da cui ancora
deve deve difendersi
per farlo mi sono affidato alla sua
storia alla storia della musica
elettronica una storia che seppur
giovane è nobile piena di significato
che tocca delle corde molto particolari
una storia che mi piacerebbe alla quale
mi piacerebbe fare affezionare anche chi
di voi Qua in sala non è non è
appassionato di musica elettronica non è
appassionato di discoteca non è
appassionato di dj però quello che a me
interessa è di farvi provare con i miei
racconti e o con i miei articoli le
stesse emozioni che ho provato io
per farlo
Ho usato uno degli strumenti più potenti
che a mio avviso esistono nel mondo la
parola
la parola che in un mondo come quello di
oggi
dominato dall'immagine sta avendo una
profonda crisi soprattutto la parola
scritta no su Instagram ormai contano le
foto su Tik Tok contano i video i
balletti tornando al ballo ci sarebbe un
altro Ted da fare su questo ma non
stasera invece D'altro canto crisi della
parola scritta grande recupero della
tradizione orale e per recupero della
tradizione orale mi riferisco al
successo di un formato che sicuramente
conoscerete al quale sicuramente sarete
affezionati Magari il formato podcast
sono molto affezionato il formato
podcast perché
si appoggia proprio all'Antica
tradizione ancestrale orale dei vecchi
miti di quelli che ballavano nella slide
che non ci sono per raccontare storie
moderne
quello che cerco di fare con i miei
racconti è un
lavoro ambizioso cioè provo a recuperare
il dall'antichità la struttura del
vecchio mito in modo particolare la
scrittura mitologica quella della
letteratura della scrittura classica
greca importante perché veniva preparata
per gli oratori che dovevano e
poidulcorare
edulcolarla sopra
un tappeto musicale
e un po' forse ambiziosamente è un po'
Forse presuntuosamente
ho deciso di
applicare alle ai miei racconti
radiofonici e il topos letterario della
musica alla musica cioè cosa intendo
sono andato a ripescare il vecchio mito
e soprattutto una teoria legata alla
mitologia classica greca che ho ritenuto
un ottimo riferimento per le mie storie
la teoria del viaggio dell'eroe la
teoria del viaggio dell'eroe è stata
teorizzata in epoca recente da uno
sceneggiatore americano che si chiama
Christopher foggler lavora per Disney ha
scritto Film sceneggiato film però
Hollywood è stato docente a io sia lei
questo professore ha elaborato Questa
teoria del viaggio dell'eroe che ho
deciso e ho tentato di applicare ai miei
racconti radio come ad esempio alla
storia di uno dei dj più famosi del
mondo che anche di Reggio Emilia quindi
dell'Emilia Romagna che magari
conoscerete anche che si chiama Benny
Benassi voglio farvi un esempio concreto
di quello che faccio in radio quando
racconto i dj e i miti della musica
attuale
il viaggio la sceneggiatura di disco
ball si basa sostanzialmente su due
grandissimi strutture quella del mondo
ordinario è quella del mondo secondo del
mondo straordinario la storia di belli
menassi parte assolutamente da un mondo
ordinario quello della provincia di
Reggio Emilia siamo negli anni 70 dove i
richiami e lo stimolo ai propri sogni
che sono quelli musicali sono
continuamente rifiutati ad un certo
punto le robe rivelarsi Cosa fa incontra
il suo mentore il Dj Albertino che gli
permette di varcare la soglia del mondo
ordinario per entrare nel mondo
straordinario dove dover affrontare
delle prove si avvicinerà il successo ci
sarà la prova centrale che è il disco
Satisfaction che gli permetterà di
diventare famoso in tutto il mondo di
vincere un sacco di premi e di tornare
trionfante a casa
questo modello che io mi diverto ad
applicare alle mie storie radiofoniche
mi diverta che perché applicabile la
storia di tutti noi Provate a immaginare
la vostra storia applicata a questo
schema vedrete che vi divertirete a
creare il vostro percorso che
sicuramente è un percorso minimo mitico
Scusate così come il viaggio dell'eroe
si distingue in tre atti anche la
declinazione del mio programma
radiofonico avviene in tre atti La prima
è il disco ball radiofonico classico che
va in onda la domenica sera alle 22:00
su M2O è una forma classica classica
perché alla musica posso aggiungere le
parole e viceversa le parole alla musica
e questo è il primo modo che ho di
raccontare la musica
il secondo modo invece è quello podcast
dove invece non esistono le parole per
definizione ma abbiamo soltanto non
esiste la musica per definizione ma
abbiamo soltanto le parole ed è qui che
è molto complicato perché qua soltanto
attraverso l'uso della parola io devo
riuscire a trasformare la musica in
emozione e Credetemi non è assolutamente
facile soprattutto perché come me tratta
una musica molto particolare che la
musica elettronica che spesso è una
musica astratta una musica senza parole
dove non ho nessun tipo di appiglio se
non quello di creare un mondo
straordinario e portarvi lì dentro con
me
la terza declinazione del mio programma
radiofonico invece sono le cure playlist
Cioè non ci sono le parole c'è soltanto
la musica
sottovalutavo questo aspetto del mio
programma E invece Credetemi la
creazione di una playlist è una cosa
emozionante eccitante quando creiamo
quando ho creato una playlist voi state
dando il suono del vostro mondo state
dando la colonna sonora della vostra
giornata Quando Scegliete quella canzone
per per fare la doccia per andare a fare
sport
per innamorarvi per disinnamorarvi
questo è il potere che sono la musica
non di sostituire perché non niente può
sostituire le vostre emozioni ma
quantomeno di assecondarle quando siete
tristi ascoltate musica triste quando
siete felici ascoltate musica felice
perché la musica vi accompagna in questo
percorso La musica è l'arte più potente
per accompagnarvi in questo percorso
se il paragone DJ mito eroe antica
Grecia non vi convince ve ne faccio uno
magari un pochino più semplice che un
pochino più meno meno sexy diciamo così
Meno affascinante Però magari più più
diretto il dj è come uno chef il dj
Seleziona e assembla ingredienti che
sono le canzoni per creare piatti unici
originali che sono i dj set che sono i
dischi che sono gli album che sono le
scalette di un concerto se il piatto
dello chef è buono voi tornerete a
mangiare in quel locale se la playlist
del DJ è buona voi tornerete ad
ascoltare quel programma la radio
tornerete a quel
tornerete a comprare quel disco E questa
cosa è è meravigliosa questa cosa
proprio è È veramente emozionante Io
però sono qua per raccontarvi un modo
credo originale Spero divertente anche
di raccontare la musica ma una cosa è
certa io non potrà non potrò mai
sostituirmi alla vostra esperienza
fisica quello che posso fare con il mio
racconto È soltanto inserirmi in quello
spazio che c'è tra la vostra esperienza
fisica e il mio racconto più piccolo è
quello spazio che c'è tra la mia storia
e l'esperienza musicale che andrete a
fare magari prima dopo avermi ascoltato
prima più piccolo è quello spazio più la
mia missione sarà andata a compimento
più la mia storia avrà fatto centro e
avrò fatto 100 nel vostro cuore con la
musica che propongo alla radio nel mio
programma radiofonico
bellissima L'Antica Grecia Tutto molto
bello gli antichi la tradizione orale
Poi a un certo punto Arriva internet
arriva internet che drammaticamente
cambia drasticamente i valori i cinque
sensi sono annullati e i social network
in modo particolare hanno cambiato le
coordinate chi come me racconta la
musica oggi nell'era dei social deve
fare particolare attenzione a nuovi
elementi che non pensavo non pensavamo
di dover affrontare nuovi nuove
variabili impazzite bisogna Innanzitutto
soprattutto sui social fare molta
attenzione a non confondere la forma
dalla sostanza e Credetemi che a volte
non è facile il confine veramente labile
bisogna avere bisogna sapere che oggi
abbiamo a che fare con un audio di
nessun target di riferimento musicale
molto giovane sono veramente piccoli
totale di alcuni generi musicali e
questo cambia il racconto sia da parte
nostra che dobbiamo darlo sia da quello
che riceviamo indietro perché questa
nuova audience giovane è veloce rapida
consuma la vita in 15 secondi consuma la
musica in 15 secondi Quindi la domanda
che mi faccio è quanto internet oggi
influenza quello che facciamo noi in
radio quello che faccio io quanto
influenza il mio racconto musicale
voglio chiudere con una provocazione
Volevo farvi questa domanda Se tutte le
piattaforme di streaming togliessero i
numeri i playse visualizzazioni saremmo
ancora in grado di capire il vero valore
di un artista o di una canzone saremmo
ancora in grado da soli senza numeri di
capire cosa ci piace cosa non ci piace
qualsiasi sia la risposta La musica è
malattia e cura allo stesso tempo e io
non voglio assolutamente guarire
Buonanotte
[Applauso]